so Jay if I went to Korea yeah yeah yeah
and I gave you a jingle a jingle okay a
phone call okay that was kind I didn't
go not a jingle but like a um no one
calls a phone call A J no I thought I
thought you me like you gave me like a
song to sing is that what I was thought
you said Okay a call yeah yeah I'm not
going to go
go czy you like it you like that yeah
yeah I want half the money
sample sample yeah but uh No I gave you
a phone call yeah okay all right yeah
would you hang out with me there of
course and you take you take me to a
restaurant yeah and nightclubs we could
okay yeah which one would you take me to
um I would probably like a restaurant
yeah would would you what do you prefer
like do you like I here's what I do want
cuz you know I've I've only [__] with
Korea Town food yeah you we've eaten a
lot together right and so I want to know
compare comparative to Korea so I'd
probably take it to like a cream
barbecue spot yeah and you know the best
one uh I know a lot of ones I don't know
of the like I don't know if there's like
the best one but there's a lot of good
ones but there's some very good ones
there's very good ones and would I eat
it and go oh this tastes a little
different than Korea
Town um well maybe the reason why is
because it's h so it's you know um beef
that or cattle that are raised in Korea
so
hopefully like no no no they're treated
well like wag style you know I me like
all of them yeah no for real really yeah
the good high quality ones yeah all of
them yeah I don't know there's no ghetto
one we we we'll take a we'll take a
survey okay you eat it you're like
delicious oh it is good every time I eat
it I will say I don't know if it's like
drastically different from like K toown
would you say I mean there's some high
quality stuff I mean it's k toown k
toown Korean food is very good it has a
a deep history in it too so it has its
own flavor and style and then same with
Korea so but is it true I've heard some
like big chefs say yeah that Korea Town
has better Korean food than Korea no
would you say that no I don't think so
no that's that's I think David Chang
said that David Chang yeah Chang said
that wait is he Korean American he is
he's one of the greatest chefs in the
world okay yeah thank you well he but by
the way I ate I ate with David Chang
last
night no I I did I wanted no
how I love he called you we were no
we're shooting some branding thing
together guys what shooting oh you're
shooting last night too huh I was
shooting some interesting lowkey flexing
right now I'm not trying to flex I don't
know why that keeps coming up but I just
wanted to bring it up because that's the
first time I met him and really hung out
with him rub it the first time I hung
out with him good dude yeah good dude
yeah dude never called me but you know
he has my
number but you take all of your dates to
his
restaurant don't say that because now I
can't take any more
dates right that's insane like what's
his restaurant major Domo major Domo
major Domo okay but what I like about it
yeah have you been there I've not okay
what I like about it it's downtown but
it's in a different area right it's like
more northern China industrial
industrial and um I have to say the food
is very good have you been there is we
went together what are you talking about
we went together remember it was like
Stephy me and you remember we ate
there okay I have you eaten with you
Stephy yeah it was three oh that was
good do you remember that no what yeah
don't remember well he doesn't remember
[__] I eat a lot you know I eat three
times a day and if you accumulate it
multi times seven yeah yeah yeah that's
a lot of eating dude but it'd be rare
that we'd be going out to Major DMO
together so I that you remember I've
gone there so many times though that's
it's like yeah but you know it was a
pleasant time and thank
you you don't mean that at all anyway
you should go if you're ever in you're
now but yeah yeah for for sure I'll try
it out yeah and like do you ever plan on
coming to Korea no why why that's
exactly why I mean because I the last
time I was there yeah not
that here's here's here's the thing I
don't know the language yeah I don't
feel Korean yeah when I'm there yeah I
feel like an American yeah right and I
feel like and they don't know me either
which is fine right but I also I was
with my brother Steve and we only ate at
One Restaurant because we didn't know
where to go no one called me you know I
mean I didn't have any friends wait how
long ago JP was there how long ago was
this 14 years ago maybe well yeah it's
much different than 14 years ago though
he was he was in a BTS music video yeah
not BTS Wonder Girls Wonder no JP was
the guy called me JP flew me out what
year was this this was a long time ago
14 years ago was like 2008 n did I meet
you then no it was like yeah right
before right before so well that's what
I'm saying it's much different now
what's changed I mean everything
everything has changed there's so many
more foreigners there now there's so
many more people that speak English
there and then there's the internet with
social media like YouTube podcast it's
it's a much even out here is if when the
landscape is different it's much
different there's a handful of tiger
belly fans out there if you did up I
know that Danny Cho lives out there
Danny and so I that's another guy I
would probably call yes and and there
all there's a big standup uh like
comedian movement out there that's
happening right now is the leader of
yeah so I mean you would they would be
honor interesting yeah they' be honored
to have you there can I ask you a
cultural question um how do they view
gay I don't know it's it's weird because
like there there is like a gay celebrity
his name is
uh
no so he's he's he's he's openly gay and
so he's on there oh he's he's open he's
open he's openly gay and he's like he's
you know he's a celebrity and he's been
doing it for a long time so he's very
well he an actor actor personality and
so yeah and he he's very well- loved out
there uhuh and there's this um
transgender um woman there's a lot of
called punja and she's very popular on
YouTube really there's a really is that
the mukbang you know the mukbang um
transgender like a heavy set person it
might be it might be punja might be
punja so there's a lot of drag and and
transgender personalities that are
really popular in Korea right now so I
think it it's much more open than it was
like 10 years back or 14 years back you
know what my dad said growing up yeah
number one no gay Kore number two if
you're gay everybody die I I kill
everybody yeah like what my friends your
friend friendy they all Li that's what
you I like what the [__] I'm okay that
wait where's your father where's your
father from what kind of what kind yeah
what ACC that's Korean in San Diego bar
yeah I'm sorry do you know what part of
Korea
you're mean well I just did an
impression with my dad how do you know
what he sounds like I don't know I
just [__] you dude D what's your dad's
story like is he he's Korea and what did
what he grew up in the Korean War yeah
he was a street kid so he never went to
school right and then he boxed in the
military oh wow and then um he was like
a like a gang like not gang but he would
steal he was a thief yeah during the
Korean War he would pick pocket and
stuff